laughs good morning good morning so
here's how it works pet stores alert
customers in with a cute but expensive
pet like a puppy then the customers sign
what they believe is a loan that will
allow them to make low monthly payments
for the pet but it's not really alone
it is a lease and customers often don't
realize until it's too late I was just
appalled Cortney Peterman says she
thought she was taking out a three
thousand dollar loan to buy dogs Kass
and max at a Connecticut pet store in
2015 she signed a contract made a one
hundred and eighty seven dollar payment
and took the dogs home eighteen months
later Peterman expected the loan to be
paid off but she called the bank and was
told she had almost 20 more payments to
go when I asked how that was possible
when it was only a three thousand dollar
loan and I was what wasn't alone at that
point it was Elyse she kept making
payments fearing the worst about what
would happen if she defaulted I was like
okay what bills am I not gonna pay now
so that way I can make sure no one's
gonna knock on my door and take my dogs
away the contract was with the leasing
company wags Peterman signed it
electronically at the store and admits
she didn't read it carefully when it was
sent to her later this is simply a
business that's built on deception and
cruelty Jenny Lind is with the ASPCA
just like someone who goes to a car
dealership people get distracted
thinking about the monthly payment and
might not then no longer negotiate that
sticker price once they start adding in
the fees all of a sudden her dogs and
you could have bought for fifteen
hundred dollars as five thousand but
more trouble comes trying to get out of
the contract even people whose pets have
died during the course of the lease are
continued to be expected to pay if the
pet that you're leasing dies you are
still responsible for paying however
many months and war years are left on
the contract yes the first question
consumers need to ask is is this Elyse
Leslie fares an attorney with the
Federal Trade Commission she says pet
leasing has been on the FTC's radar for
about three years and while it's not
illegal pet shops can be held
responsible companies have an obligation
to make sure for
that consumers know it Solis second that
the terms are very clear upfront
consumers need to read these contracts
very very carefully Peterman was able to
get out of her lease after filing a
complaint with the Better Business
Bureau in the end she paid about fifty
six hundred dollars to officially own
the dogs don't finance a dog ever if you
don't have the means to pay for a dog
you shouldn't be paying for one last
year California and Nevada banned pet
leasing this year New York is expected
to become the third state to ban the
practice we reached out to the
Connecticut pet store where Courtney
Peterman bought her dogs and have not
heard back
wags lending would not provide a comment
for our story and you guys know we've
all reported on what it's like to be
called by collection agencies yeah got
kids they love the dog and all of a
sudden the collector is saying if you
don't pay we're going to get the dog no
one wants to give the dog back now the
animals are like family members it is
impossible to imagine giving them up in
someone's come and go is it bad for me
to say let your like dog gonnit I
shouldn't say that's pretty good Nora
okay you're allowed to pun thank the pun
friendly zone